How's it goin', my name is Markiplier
I was... *creepy sound*
Okay, I thought you were gonna slam the dooooooo-oh, oh you're not done!?
Oh you be thumpy thump real hard out on that bing bong down out stairs!
Oh god
That's... oookay!
Ahh! Fuck! You!
Oh, God! Ah! Okay! We're running! We're running away now! We're running away as fast as we can!
No. No, I don't wanna play.
Fuuuck. What do I do?
Ahhh! Woaahh-o! Mmm-he-eyy! In-da-naahhh! *monster noises*
What else you got for me game? Huh? Ya actually gonna be spooky? Huh? You gonna try to scare me?
*door slams* Heeeeeeyyyyyyyy!
*Down With The Sickness by Disturbed plays in the background*
Ooh wa-ah-ah-ah!
Ahh-hhh!
Oh-oh!
This is my favorite part, oh-oh!
I got a bad feeling about this...
*gasp* *sigh* Mmm....
*sniff* *sniff* *sniff*
Hang on, my nose is runnin'
Don't think I need it, I can do it.
I DON'T NEED IT, I NEED IT!
Uhhhhhh-eeyy-ah okay, alright!
Wooooooaaahhhhh
All right, I'm runnin'. Oh, it's right by me. Ohhh, where do I go?
Lightning, please, thank you Thor, can you please kick it up a notch?
They're everywhere....
Ah! They're right there!
Narnia-wah-yEEYYY!
Oh? Ah! Get 'em off! Ah! Frick! Ah, my face! Ohh God!
Oh God I'm getting sandwiched in between two!
If they're into ritualistic sacrifice, then hey, uhhhh
The party's heeeeere! Oh, fuck! *old lady saying "hey" angrily*
Is he coming after me? *gasp* Ooookay, fuck you! I can't move!
Oh God! Close the door! Get in the *unintelligible word*! Ahh-heeyyy, fuck you! Ohh God!
He'll never get me in heeereee
*pounding on door*
Eh? Errrrr... body dump?
*pounding on door* body dump?!? Okay, I go down the body dump... *pounding on door*
Weeeeoohoooooo!
Ah.
Ah, okay, alright. Well the party came and went...
Whooooooooooooooooooooo...
What the fuck is wrong with you? Okay, goodbye!
Sooo I guess this is how we're gonna play this game, ooooohhkkaayy!
Who the fuck are you?
It's a chain link death funnel pointing me into the death building where I got to go turn off the death antennas...
All right fine, whatever. Let's do this.
Is that a babu giraffe? Ohhhh, it's..adorable. Ohhhhhhhhh, it's adorable.
Ohhhh, it's got a blood on it. Ah that makes it twice as adorable.
My sister's old book. Okay, what good is that gonna do me?
My sister's old dresser. Okay, great.
My sister's old pai- *gasp*
*sigh* Didn't scare me.
Oh, hey. Ohhh, my God. That's astonishingly creepy
*creepy noises*
Ooookay? Alrighty then. Good to meet ya Shrek. HEY!
Oh grand-ma-ma! You're looking so....alive!
Very strange from last time I saw you when I was at your funeral.
Also, I-I can't fathom what the point of these... *creepy sound*
You know what I'm done questioning things, I get it. I understand. I'm about to die, I-I know this
I-I should just accept my fate... keel over and just... kiss my ass goodbye. Hellooo
Oh fuck you, Ohhh fuck. Ohhh fuck.
Seems awfully wet in here
Alright, so... just to set the mood a little.. *gasp*
Fucking goddamn it!
Stooppp!
Hey!
Fuzz bitch!
Fuzz butt! Nah... that's cute name
Fu... fu......
Fuuuuuuuuuuuuckkkkk yoouuuuu!
I like me a good rune.
Was that a naked streaker..? Was that a streaker? Was that a streaker in the middle of this goddamn mine?
Was there someone running naked in this goddamn mine cuz that's something that I will not stand for okay?
Uuuughh!
Why aren't they after the balls, why am I after the balls?
Frankly I can do without the balls.
Okay, you know what, I'm-
Yeah, I'm okay, that didn't happen
That's uhm...
someone connecting to the internet.. from the 1994's?
That was a good joke me. Thanks.
Ooh-way-wooaah-ohh
Come onnnn, do it for meeeee, come onnnnn!
Oh God, not that, that's not what I wanted, you're a big pellet, I don't want you. You gobble something else.
I'm trusting this. I don't know why I'm trusting this. Oh boy.
OOHHHHHHHHHHH YEEAAAAAAHHH!!!
Grandma if you could stop pranking me...
I'm gonna sneeze, I'm gonna fear sneeze
Uh
Ah
Oh, God
Ahh-I-ah..I'm not sneezing. Ah, Jesus. Hh-yahk.
Oh, you want some? Oh you want some of my sexy body?
But you can't have it! You can't have it! You couldn't handle all of this sexy, not with that stupid mouth of yours.
Oh. Never mind, then
Grandma?
HEYYYY!